séductrice si quelqu'un me plaît je me
transforme en tchat
ok c'est dans tu parles pendant une
heure d'interview epic arcs va éclater
juste un truc et vous faites comment la
chatte mais c'est comme ça là c'est le
chat br j'aurai donc vous et vous vous
faites quoi vous jennifer je vais sortir
[Musique]
c'est bête
non non mais si oui c'est bête parce que
je voulais reparler de ma déclaration
album de jenifer malheureusement je vais
plus parler du livre de patrick
politique quand je sors aussi jean
michel maire tient jean michel maire
pour l'aviron ennuie jamais ce n'est pas
la personne ne vous connais pas ce que
je vois à la télé parfois mais donc du
coup pourquoi vous à dire beaucoup non
[Musique]
pascal lacombe et le poker d'affaires du
coup non non c'est quoi mais bon ça se
voit et ça non
pour la nuit alors mais regardez pour
l'adhésion de sun mary seela demain à
bien un jour je décide de mettre du
rouge à lèvres son voyage à l'ibis et
j'ai une tendance à frotter main ma
bouche contre le micro quand je chante
parfois et je m'en rendais pas compte on
fait ça comprenez quoi le québec et le
canada n'ont pas noté l'a impressionné
plus jamais rien
elle danse et j'adore ce look huawei
franchement on va bien on va partir sur
un garçon a look comme ça on sur un vrai
sport est pas moi c'est vrai tous les
cas ce sont nos amis de la famille à
watten goût il ya chez valve lot mais
toi tu te fais jamais de délires
capillaires du reste de ta paix
quelques-uns ah oui c'est vrai j'ai été
rousse vénitienne pendant trois jours il
n'y a pas longtemps sur sur la vie de ma
mère ouais c'est mon fantasme en fait
des rançons blonde platine mais je suis
resté deux jours comme ça ta patrie fait
l'impossible vous savez que les faits -
jour ou au seuil par way of heroes blond
aussie vous avez fait et ferrou j'étais
encore sur des parents et je suis passé
devant la chambre de mes parents et à ma
mère qui était mon père si tu avais vu
ce que je viens de voir
l'histoire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]